just how disappointing is it to now have
back-to-back games where you are hearing
booze at home and maybe you felt again
that some of those booze or many of them
were deserved from the effort that your
team showed out there yeah we deserved
it for sure um you know fell fell behind
immediately um and uh I think I think
we're just lacking confidence right now
you know it's it's um you uh you you
just sort of um you know you you get to
a stage sometimes where um um you just
kind of lose your uh your belief and um
it happens um and that's what's happened
right now with our team the last few
days I think we've um you know we've
just lost um the the spirit the
confidence that that has to carry you
you know against um talented teams night
in and night out some of your roughest
nights this season have been kind of
like blown leads um but are these two
nights the LA is is this a more
concerning you know thing to happen of
course of course yeah we weren't
competitive these last two two games and
um you know that one of the coaches um
on the way down said we're we're we're
the quietest team ever you know and and
uh I think without without Draymond and
Chris it's really exposed just um
there's there's not much chatter
defensively there's you know we have we
do have a very quiet group of guys um
you know with this particular team
that's out there now and and we probably
need a a pickme up we need Draymond we
need Chris we need you know we guys who
can um kind of rally the troops right
now and um it's um you know when you're
going through it like this um it's only
one way out and that's to fight together
to compete together and somehow we got
to get stops I mean you know we gave up
141 points they scored it will and um
you know we we have to be able to get
stops to be to be
competitive